ओके
सो चलिए तो वी आर लाइव नाउ
गाइस लेट मी चेक
वंस मैं देख लेता हूं एक बार आप भी मुझे
बता दीजिए चैट में ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ
सही है एक बार बता दीजिए जल्दी से सभी लोग
बता दीजिए ऑडियो वीडियो एवरीथिंग इज गुड
गुड इवनिंग सबको नमस्ते प्लीज कंफर्म
गाइस
ओके ओके यस यस ठीक
है ठीक
है ओ चलिए बढ़िया
तो सो काफी लोग आ चुके हैं य पर वेलकम
वेलकम वेलकम एवरी
बडी काफी टाइम बाद क्लास आज हो रही है एंड
काफी एक इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक काफी एक शानदार
टॉपिक पर हम आज की क्लास करने वाले हैं
एंड आई होप कि आप सबने ट को जवाइन कर लिया
होगा
राइट ट ग्रुप जो हमने क्रिएट किया है आप
सब के लिए उसे आप सबने जवाइन कर लिया है
एंड मैं ऐसी उम्मीद करता हूं आपसे कि आप
में से हर एक बंदा ट ग्रुप को जवाइन करेगा
क्योंकि यह ग्रुप इस मोटिव से क्रिएट किया
गया है कि जितने भी एस्पायरिंग बग बाउंट
हंटर्स हैं जितने भी एंथिया हैं जो बग
बाउंट में अपना करियर देखते हैं फ्यूचर
में कहीं ना कहीं अपने आप को उस लेवल प
देखते हैं सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर बनना चाहते
हैं एक एक रियल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर बनना
चाहते हैं दे वुड बी जॉइनिंग द
वाले अभी डेज 26 वाले तो आपको व ग्रुप का
लिंक मिल जाएगा मैं चैट में भी दे देता
हूं
व
ग्रुप ठीक है तो मैं यहां पर चैट में एक
बार दे देता हूं जस्ट वेट यह ग्रुप का
लिंक है मैं लिंक चैट में दे देता हूं आप
लोग यहां से भी जवाइन कर सकते हैं ग्रुप
को ठीक है मैंने दे दिया यहां
पर एंड मैंने मैसेज को पिन भी कर दिया है
यू ऑल कैन सी द मैसेज नाउ राइट तो आप इसको
जवाइन कर लीजिएगा ये आप सबके लिए बनाया
गया है कम्युनिटी बनाई गई है आप यहां पे
अपने डाउट्स को भी पूछ सकते हैं एक दूसरे
से डिस्कशन कर सकते हैं एक दूसरे के
प्रॉब्लम को सॉल्व कर सकते हैं क्योंकि
मैं मानता हूं कि एक कम्युनिटी के अंदर एक
कम्युनिटी बहुत स्ट्रांग हो सकती है अगर
एक दूसरे से मिलके उसमें एक दूसरे की
हेल्प की जाए तो आप एक दूसरे की
प्रॉब्लम्स को सॉल्व कर सकते हैं एक दूसरे
से अपने नॉलेज को शेयर कर सकते हैं अपने
जो भी बग बाउंट के स्किल्स है उसको शेयर
कर सकते हैं एंड दूसरों को समझा सकते बता
सकते ठीक है
चलिए इट्स ओके व ग्रुप बन चुका है बन चुका
है आपको लिंक जा चुका है गाइस ठीक है आप
पिंड जो कमेंट उसको देख
लीजिए ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट चलिए बढ़िया सो
गाइस स्टार्ट करने से पहले एस यूजुअल मैं
आपको बता देता हूं यह हमारा डेनिक्स का
लिंकडन पेज है आप इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
क्योंकि जितने भी अपडेट्स जो भी नई-नई
चीजें आएंगी कंपनी के रिलेटेड हमारे साइट
से आप सबके लिए वह यहीं पर मिलेंगी आपको
यह हमारा
twittersignin.com
चलिए वेलकम अब मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि
गाइस मेरी तबीयत कुछ खास ठीक नहीं है फिर
भी क्योंकि मैंने शेड्यूल करा था क्लास आप
सबका तो मेरे को क्लास लेना था एंड
शेड्यूल करने से पहले मेरी तबीयत बिल्कुल
सही थी बट
सुबह मतलब ऐसा मान के चलो सुबह के टाइम
में दोपहर के टाइम से ऐसा कुछ थोड़ा सा
डाउन फील हो रहा है एंड थोड़ी सी गड़बड़ ल
लग रही है तो फिर भी मैं थोड़ा स्लो मैं
थोड़ा आराम आराम से ही आपको कराऊंगा जो भी
चीजें आपको कराऊंगा बताऊंगा सिखाऊंगा तो
आप उसमें थोड़ा सा बियर अप कीजिएगा एंड
मेरे साथ रहिए ज्यादा एनर्जी ज्यादा मैं
आज नहीं लगा सकता शायद आपके लिए बट स्टिल
आपको एनर्जेटिक रहना है आपको अपनी एनर्जी
डाउन नहीं करनी है ठीक है चलिए
सो ओके तो अभी गाइस अपन स्टार्ट करते हैं
आज के सेशन को और आज की जो क्लास है वो हम
होस्ट डर इंजेक्शन पर करने वाले हैं बहुत
ही बहुत ही अमेजिंग वनरे बिलिटी है होस्ट
हेडर इंजेक्शन ठीक
है अब होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन यस शमीम
यस होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन में क्या होता है
मैं आपको थोड़ा सा उसका ओवरव्यू दे देता
हूं ठीक है ना चलिए होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन
मैं यहां पर सर्च करता हूं सिंपल एंड यहां
पर मैं सर्च करूंगा तो मुझे यहां पर
रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे ओस का एक रिजल्ट आपको
मिलेगा होस्टड इंजेक्शन का तो आपको यहां
पे इसकी समरी मिलेगी एंड टेस्टिंग का कुछ
गाइड मिलेगा आपको एंड इसके थ्रू क्या-क्या
की जा सकती है सारी चीजें मिलेंगी तो समरी
को आप पढ़ेंगे तो आपको इसका आईडिया लग
जाएगा बट मैं इसको थोड़ा सा इजी वे में
आपको समझाऊ ज्यादा आपको समझ में आएगा
होस्ट नेट इंजेक्शन के बारे में बट जब हम
होस्ट हेडर की बात करते हैं ना तो हम हेडर
की बात करें यहां पे हम पर्टिकुलर हेडर्स
की बात कर रहे हैं उसमें भी किस हेडर की
होस्ट की बात करें होस्ट हेडर की ठीक है
हेडर्स के अंदर में ना आप देखोगे
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स होते हैं रिस्पांस
हेडर्स होते हैं ये सब आपको पता है राइट
अब अगर आपको नहीं पता तो मैं आपको बता
देता हूं ऑलरेडी इस पे वीडियो मैंने डाली
हुई है ऑलरेडी हमारा एक सेशन हुआ था इसके
ऊपर अगर सभी लोग ध्यान से फॉलो करते हैं
सारी वीडियोस को तो आप जब चैनल पे जाएंगे
हमारे डि फ्रक्स अकेडमी के लाइव सेक्शन
में जरा सा स्क्रॉल करेंगे आप तो यहां पे
आपको एक क्लास मिलेगी डे 21 वाली एचटीटीपी
हेडर्स फॉर फाइंडिंग मोर बक्स मैं आपको
रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा कि यह वीडियो जरूर देख
लीजिएगा ठीक है ना इसमें आपको हेडर्स के
बारे में जानकारी हो जाएगी बहुत डिटेल वे
में ठीक है चलिए
तो यहां पर हेडर्स के अंदर बहुत सारे
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स होते हैं रिस्पांस
हेडर्स होते हैं और उन रिस्पांस और
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स के अंदर में ठीक है ना
सारे एक हेडर होता है होस्ट वैसे ही
हेडर्स होते हैं कुकीज होते हैं सेट कुकीज
होते हैं यह सब हेडर्स है कोई रिक्वेस्ट
का है कोई रिस्पांस का हेडर है ठीक है
एक्स
फॉरवर्ड होस्ट एक हेडर होता है ठीक है ना
रेफरर एक हेडर होता है यूजर एजेंट एक हेडर
होता है वैसे ही एक होस्ट हेडर होता है
ठीक है यह कैसे कैसा दिखता है मैं आपको यह
दिखाने की कोशिश करता हूं व्हाट आई एम
गोइंग टू डू मैं यहां पे चलता हूं इसमें
बब शूट के अंदर में मैं फिलहाल इसको बंद
कर देता हूं टारगेट प चलता हूं मैं यहां
पे ठीक है एंड यहां पे
मैं कोई सा भी एक ले लेता हूं लाइक कोई सी
भी एक टारगेट को ले लेता हूं जैसे ये
टारगेट है एनालिटिक्स डॉट twitter.com ठीक
है हम इसी को ले लेते हैं और इसको मैं
सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देता हूं मैं रिपीटर पर
आ जाऊंगा यहां पर तो यहां पर आपको यहां पर
कुछ चीजें दिखेंगी राइट यहां पर आपको दिख
रही है यहां पे यह एक रिक्वेस्ट हेडर है
जिसमें ऊपर का लाइन यहां पर आपको दिख रहा
है यहां पर गेट रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है इस
पर्टिकुलर पाथ प टीम टीपीएम प एंड एसटी
वर्जन है नेक्स्ट जो आपका कॉलम होता है वह
होस्ट का यहां पर आपको दिख रहा है इसी
होस्ट हेडर की हम बात कर रहे हैं इसी के
अंदर हम ना
कुछ अजीब सी चीजें करने वाले हैं कुछ ऐसा
करने वाले हैं जिससे कि मजा आ जाएगा आपको
आपको लगेगा अरे भाई यह क्या हो रहा है एंड
एक्चुअली इसको एक्सप्लोइट किया जा सकता है
बाय हैकर्स इसको एक्सप्लोइट करके बहुत
तरह-तरह की चीजें की जा सकती हैं जैसे कि
होस्ट को एक्सप्लोइट करके कोई भी अटैकर जो
है अगर होस्ट को या होस्ट हेड इंजेक्शन के
थ्रू एक मलसियन कंट्रोल्ड एविल मलिसिया या
हैकर कंट्रोल्ड डोमेन पे रीडायरेक्ट किया
जा सकता है अभी करंट होस्ट को जो कि एक
मलेशियन कॉम्प्रोमाइज वेबसाइट हो सकती है
या एक फिशिंग वेबसाइट हो सकती है या एक
ऐसी वेबसाइट्स जो बहुत लेजर दिखती है बट
वो मिलिशिया होगी वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग की जा
सकती है वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग अटैक्स होती हैं
उनको परफॉर्म किया जाता है पासवर्ड रिसेट
पॉइजनिंग अटैक्स जो होती है उसको परफॉर्म
किया जा सकता है इसके साथ ही एक्सेसेस जी
हां क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग अटैक को
परफॉर्म किया जा सकता है एसएसआरएफ काइंड
ऑफ भी एसएसआरएफ तक को आप इस पर परफॉर्म की
कर सकते हैं हालांकि एसएसआरएफ के बारे में
अभी अभी नहीं पता हमने उसको पढ़ा नहीं है
बट मैं उसके लिए अलग से सेपरेट एक क्लास
आपको लूंगा जिसमें एसएसआरएफ पे आपकी सारी
जो कंफ्यूजन है जो भी आपके अ एसएसआरएफ के
बारे में हर चीज हम उसमें बात करेंगे ठीक
है तो यही आपका होस्ट हेडर होता है अब
देखिए ये काम कैसे करता है इस पे इसको हम
देखेंगे थोड़ा समझेंगे पहले ठीक है अब
देखो आज के टाइम में क्या आईपी वर्जन फर
की कमी हुई है ठीक है मैं यहां पे ना एक
वेबसाइट है व्यू डीएनएस इंफो इस पे चलता
हूं ठीक
है चलो अब आईपी वर्जन फोर की जैसे-जैसे
कमी होती गई ना आईपी की तो वैसे-वैसे क्या
हुआ कि जो भी
हमारे प्रोवाइडर्स हैं जहां से आप
होस्टिंग वगैरह लेते हो तो उन्होंने
शेयर्ड होस्टिंग का ऑप्शन देना शुरू किया
ठीक है शेयर्ड होस्टिंग का इसका मतलब है
एक सर्वर के रिसोर्स को एक सर्वर के
रिसोर्स जो भी सर्वर है उसके एक रिसोर्स
को मल्टीपल वेबसाइट ओनर्स यूज कर रहे हैं
बस सिंपल सा फंडा है जैसे मेरा एक सर्वर
है मान लो मैंने क्या किया उस सर्वर पे
मल्टीपल आईपी मल्टीपल वेबसाइट्स को होस्ट
कर दिया अब उस सर्वर में मान लो लेट्स
सपोज मेरे सर्वर में 1 टेराबाइट का रम
कैपेसिटी है तो 1 24gb का है मान लो अब
उसमें से क्या है कि 4gb एक सर्वर यूज कर
रहा है 4gb एक और वेबसाइट यूज करही है 4gb
एक और ऐसे कर कर के मल्टीपल वेबसाइट्स
उसपे चल रही है एक सर्वर पे मल्टीपल
वेबसाइट्स होस्ट हो रही है कहने का मतलब
ये ठीक है तो अभी देखो मेरा भी जो यह
वेबसाइट है अपना टेक्निकल
n.in मैं इस वेबसाइट को ओपन कर लेता हूं
यह हमारी वेबसाइट
है लेट इट ओपन तो हमारी जो यह वेबसाइट है
यह भी शेयर्ड होस्टिंग के ऊपर ही है ठीक
है दिस वेबसाइट इ होस्ट ऑन शेयर्ड
होस्टिंग चलिए अब शेड होस्टिंग का मतलब
क्या है अब मैं क्या करता हूं ना व्यू
डीएनएस इंफो प चलता हूं एंड यहां पे
रिवर्स आईपी लुक अप करता हूं ये कनेक्टेड
है आज के टॉपिक से इसलिए आपका जानना जरूरी
है हम कांसेप्ट समझ रहे हैं आपको हमारा
फ्लो ऑलरेडी पता है ठीक है ना किसी भी
टॉपिक का हम फ्लो क्या रखते हैं आपको पता
है पहला हमारा क्या होता है कांसेप्ट
दूसरा जो हमारा होता है
प्रैक्टिकल हमारा पहले कांसेप्ट होता है
देन हमारा प्रैक्टिकल होता है मोस्ट
प्रोबेबली जो होती है वह लैब पर होती है
लैब प्रैक्टिकल होता है ये और तीसरा जो
हमारा स्टेप होता है वो रियल वर्ल्ड
टारगेट के ऊपर प्रैक्टिकल होता है ठीक है
यह तीन अप्रोच होते हैं जिसमें हम अभी
पहले अप्रोच प है यानी कांसेप्ट को समझ
रहे हैं इसके बिना आपका यह दोनों चीज जो
है ना दोनों यह बहुत ही बेकार है इसका कोई
फायदा नहीं होता है मेरे हिसाब से चलिए तो
रिवर्स आईपी लुक प आते हैं य लिखा है सॉरी
फाइंड ऑल साइट्स होस्टेड ऑन अ गिवन सर्वर
मैं यहां पर अपनी वेबसाइट डालता हूं
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर आ मैं गो पर क्लिक करता
हूं जैसे ही मैंने गो पर क्लिक किया आपको
यहां पर दिखेगा रिवर्स आईपी रिजल्ट्स फ
टेक्निकल नेटर आ अब इस आईपी पे जितने भी
डोमेन यहां लिस्टेड है वह सारी डोमेन या
जो भी डोमेन होस्टेड है वो दिखा रहा है बट
यहां पे बात यह है कि ये जो आईपी है ना ये
आईपी ये मेरी वेबसाइट की रियल आईपी नहीं
है ये क्लाउड फ्लेयर की आईपी है मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं मैं इसको एक्सेस करूंगा तो
यहां पे आ रहा है यू हैव रिक्वे
सॉरी तो यहां पे आएगा कि यू हैव
रिक्वेस्टेड एन आईपी एड्रेस दैट इज पार्ट
ऑफ क्लाउड फयर नेटवर्क ठीक है क्लाउड फयर
का ये आईपी है तो हमारा रियल आईपी तो नहीं
है तो हमें जो यहां पे डोमेन पता चल रहे
हैं ये क्लाउड फ्लेयर वाले होस्टेड डोमेन
है हालांकि हम इसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं एज
एग्जांपल क्योंकि ये सीडीएन पे इतने एक
सीडीएन है उसपे इतने सारे वेबसाइट होस्टेड
है तो हम अपने ओरिजिनल आईपी पे चलते हैं
तो मैं आपको किटर मैन वाली एसपीएफ ट्रिक
से आईपी खोजने की कोशिश करूंगा यहां पे तो
किटर मैन वाली वेबसाइट प आ ग जहां से हम
एसपीएफ फाइंड करते हैं अगर एसपीएफ के बारे
में नहीं पता तो आप इसके पहले वाली वीडियो
अ क्लास 25 देखिएगा जिसमें हमने
देखा था कि आप लाइक लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स
कैसे फाइंड कर सकते हो उसमें एसपीएफ प
हमने बात की है यहां पर मैं टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर डाल दूंगा एंड यहां पे मैं गेट
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड करूंगा तो कई बार एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड के अंदर में जो हमारी टी एक्सटी
रिकॉर्ड होती है उसके अंदर हमारा ओरिजिनल
आईपी जो कि रिकॉर्ड डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड के
अंदर जो ए रिकॉर्ड होता है वो जो पॉइंट
होता है बेसिकली पॉइंट करता है जिस सर्वर
आईपी प वो लीक्ड होता है तो यहां पे हमारी
रियल रियल आईपी यहां पे हमें एक मिल गई है
जो हमारी रियल आईपी है तो अगर आपको मैं
यहां पर पिंग करके दिखाऊं तो लेट्स पिंग
इट तो इट इज पिंगिफोव्यू
[संगीत]
तो आपको दिखेगा यहां पे इस आईपी के लिए
देयर आर 446 डोमस होस्टेड ऑन दिस सर्वर
मतलब इस सर्वर पे जो मेरी शेयर्ड होस्टिंग
वाली सर्वर है इस पे 446 डोमेन होस्टेड है
भाई 446 वेबसाइट चल रही है ये जो
वेबसाइट्स है ना जो वेबसाइट चल रही है एक
आईपी पर मल्टीपल वेबसाइट जब होस्ट होती है
तो वो जो मल्टीपल होस्ट वेबसाइट्स होती है
उनको वर्चुअल होस्ट बोलते हैं व्हाट दे आर
नोन एस दे आर नोन
एज मैं य पर यह टॉपिक डाल देता हूं
होस्ट हेडर
इंजेक्शन ठीक है
तो यहां पे जब
हम न मल्टीपल ऐसे कर देते हैं न
मल्टीपल वेबसाइट्स आर होस्टेड ऑन सिंगल
आईपी
दोस डोमस आर नोन
एस वर्चुअल होस्ट वर्चुअल
होस्ट उनको वर्चुअल होस्ट बोलते हैं ठीक
है
जनरली वर्चुअल होस्ट ठीक है तो जो डोमस है
यह वर्चुअल होस्ट है एक तरह का ठीक है
राइट लो आ रहा है बहुत आवाज आवाज बहुत लो
आ रही है
क्या
अ बहुत ज्यादा लो आ रही है क्या वॉइस मेरी
बता दीजिए मुझे एक बार क्योंकि मैं ज्यादा
शायद हां बट स्टिल बताइए ज्यादा तेज तो
नहीं बोल रहा बट स्टिल
बताइए ओके मैं ट्राई करता हूं थोड़ा फास्ट
थोड़ा वॉल्यूम हाई करने का अपना खुद का
मैं माइक को भी थोड़ा सा क्लोज लाता
हूं ओके
चलिए ओके ध्यान दीजिएगा यहां
पे इनको हम वर्चुअल होस्ट बोलते हैं अब
क्या होता है गाइस ट व्हाट हैपेंस कि जब
जब कोई भी रिक्वेस्ट आप करते हैं व्हेन
एवर यू डू अ रिक्वेस्ट किसी भी सर्वर से
ठीक है वट
हैपेंस मैं आपको दिखाता हूं यह विजुलाइज
थोड़ा कराता हूं ज्यादा आपको शायद अच्छा
हो पाएगा लगेगा तो जब भी कोई ब्राउजर होता
है ना यह ब्राउजर रिक्वेस्ट भेजती है यह
सर्वर को ठीक है यह सर्वर हो गया यह
ब्राउजर हो गया यानी कि क्लाइंट हो गया यह
जब रिक्वेस्ट भेजती है ना तो जो हमारे
हेडर्स होते हैं हेडर्स
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर जिनको बोलते हैं सॉरी फॉर
द राइटिंग यह मैं माउस से कर रहा हूं अभी
मेरे पास पेन नहीं है य वाला तो यह जो
हेडर्स होता है रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स यह
डिसाइड करते हैं यही डिसीज फैक्टर इनके
अंदर ही होता है यही इनके अंदर यही डिसाइड
करते हैं कि बेसिकली इसके अंदर जो कॉन्फिन
होती है इससे डिसाइड होता है कि वोह
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट कौन सी डोमेन के लिए
है कौन सी डोमेन के लिए ठीक है वो होस्ट
सेडर से हमारा डिफाइन हो जाता है सिंपल सा
फंडा है अब जैसे इसका एग्जांपल मैं आपको
समझाता हूं मैं समझा रहा हूं देखो अब ये
एक रिक्वेस्ट आई है टी स्ल टीपीएम पाथ के
लिए रिक्वेस्ट आई है ठीक है तो ये होस्ट
हेडर ही हमें डिफाइन करता है कि ये इस
पर्टिकुलर होस्ट के लिए जा रही है
twitter.com के लिए ठीक है या इस सब डोमेन
के लिए analytics.js
वही देख लेता
हूं यहां पे आ तो गया होगा मेरे ख्याल
से चलो इतना क्या खोजें यहां प्रॉक्सी प
चलते हैं इंटरसेप्ट प चलते हैं एंड हेयर
गो टू दिस वन इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कर लेते हैं
एंड इसको हम रीलोड कर लेते हैं ठीक है तो
यहां पे आ जाएगा मैं इसको फॉरवर्ड कर देता
हूं याद रखिएगा फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड
फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर ये रहा मैं इसको सेंड टू रिपीटर
कर देता हूं इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देता हूं
रिपीटर पे आ जाते हैं ये आ ग अब देखो हमने
क्या किया एक रिक्वेस्ट मेड किया किस पे
स्लश पे कहां पे स्लैश पे हमने वेबसाइट के
पैरेंट डायरेक्टरी पे हमने एक रिक्वेस्ट
मेड किया एंड ये टेक्निकल नेविगेटर आई को
ही रिक्वेस्ट गई है यह कैसे पता चला इस
हेडर से पता चला अब क्योंकि इस आईपी पे एक
पर्टिकुलर आईपी बहुत सारे डोमेन होस्टेड
है बट हमारे इसी डोमेन पे ये गया इस हमारे
इसी होस्ट हेडर से पता चलता है ठीक है अब
अगर हमने जैसे मैं गो प क्लिक करूंगा यहां
पर रिस्पांस आ जाएगा 200 ओके वाला अगर
हमने इस होस्ट हेडर के साथ कोई छेड़छाड़
कर दी
तो लेट्स सपोज अगर ये जैसे मान लो हमारा
सर्वर कौन सा है मान लो मान लो हम सर्वर
कौन सा यूज कर
रहे एटीटीपी सर्वर हमारा कौन सा है
अचय हमारा सर्वर जो है अचय यूज हो रहा है
तो अचय की एक कॉन्फिन फाइल होती है एडी
पडी क ये फाइल होती है इस फाइल के अंदर
में जो लिस्ट होती है होस्ट की होस्ट की
लिस्ट होती है जो कि वर्चुअल होस्ट लिस्ट
आप बोल सकते हैं वर्चुअल वर्चुअल होस्ट
लिस्ट होते हैं जैसे कि एक दो तीन
चर चार ऐसे करके यह लिस्टिंग हो
गई यह पाच हो गया इस तरीके से लो लिस्ट
होती है तो जब भी जब भी यहां पर मैं आपको
बता देता हूं
नवर वेन
एवर वी डू सम मिस
कन्फेशन टू द होस्ट हेडर होस्ट हेडर एंड
एंड अपाचे
रिसीव ट
रिक्वेस्ट ट
रिक्वेस्ट दे अपाचे रिसीव ट रिक्वेस्ट इट
ड नॉट बी
नोइंग व्ट
टू डू और वेयर टू सेंड दिस
रिक्वेस्ट
और वेयर व्हाट टू डू और
वच होस्ट टू सेंड दिस रिक्वेस्ट टू सेंड
दिस रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है अब अचे के पास जब ये
हमारे पास ये रिक्वेस्ट जाती है मिस
कॉन्फिन वाली मिस
कॉन्फिन कॉन्फिन वाली जब हमारे पास होस्ट
हेडर होस्ट मिस कन्फर होस्ट की रिक्वेस्ट
जाती है तो आप पाचे के एचटीटीपीडी कॉन में
वर्चुअल होस्ट की लिस्ट होती है तो इसको
पता नहीं होता एक्चुअली में कि क्या करना
है क्योंकि यह मिस कॉन्फिडो है तो सबसे
पहला जो होस्ट होता है द फर्स्ट होस्ट द
फर्स्ट वी होस्ट यह उसको यह रिक्वेस्ट
सेंड कर देता है
बेसिकली ठीक है यह उसको रिक्वेस्ट सेंड कर
देता है इसका मत इसका मतलब है कि हर एक
रिक्वेस्ट के साथ इट इज पॉसिबल टू
इंटरेक्ट विद द फर्स्ट वर्चुअल होस्ट इन द
अचे कॉन्फिन फाइल सिंपल सा ये एक कांसेप्ट
है यह समझ में आ रहा है आपको या ऊपर से जा
रहा है मुझे बताइए ईमानदारी से इना समझ
में आ रहा है
आपको
बताइए
प्लीज लेट मी नो
गाइस समझ में आया आपको कितनों के समझ में
आ चुका
है प्लीज रिप्लाई एवरीवन प्लीज रिप्लाई
एवरीवन फिर से एक बार ठीक है मैं आपको एक
मतलब वैसे तो आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखोगे तो
आपको क्लियर हो जाएगा जो मैं बोलना चाह
रहा हूं बट स्टिल आई वुड लाइक टू रिपीट इट
फॉर यू ठीक है सिंपल सा मैं रिपीट मार
देता हूं एक
बार बहुत लोगों को हो चुका
है ठीक है य नाडी प्लीज डोंट प्लीज डोंट
स्पैम स्पैम करोगे आपको यहां पर बैन कर
दिया जाएगा प्लीज ठीक है देखो सिंपल सा
फंडा मैं बताता हूं जब भी कोई कोई क्लाइंट
जो है ना सर्वर को रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है अब
मैंने जैसा कि आपको बताया ना कि एक आईपी
पे एक जो हमारी आईपी है एक आईपी
पे मल्टीपल होस्ट मल्टीपल डोमस मल्टीपल
वेबसाइट्स होस्टेड होती है मल्टीपल
वेबसाइट्स
अब जब क्लाइंट से एक रिक्वेस्ट जाती है तो
ये किस वेबसाइट के लिए जाएगी यह हमारा
होस्ट हेडर डिफाइन करता है ये हमारा होस्ट
हेडर बताता है कैसे बताता है भैया सिंपल
इसके थ्रू होस्ट हेडर होती है ये बता रहा
है टेक्निकल नेटर आ के लिए यह रिक्वेस्ट
है पर्टिकुलर लेकिन इस वेबसाइट पे इस
पर्टिकुलर आईपी पे टेक्निकल नेटर ड आ भी
है वेबसाइट एक मान लो वेबसाइट है ए बी सी
यह भी होस्टेड है एक वेबसाइट है एक्स वाई
जड तो यह भी होस्टेड है तो अब यह
रिक्वेस्ट क्योंकि होस्ट हेडर में हमारे
टी एन टेक्निकल नेविगेटर के लिए यहां पे
एंट्री है तो यह रिक्वेस्ट टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर को जाएगी एंड ये
लिस्ट जो लिस्ट होती है आपकी यह कहां पर
होती है यह आपके
अचे अचे के कॉन्फिन फाइल में होती है अचे
जो आपकी एटीटीपी सर्वर होती है इसके
कॉन्फिन फाइल होती है एक एटीपीडी क जो कि
मैंने यहां पर आपको मेंशन किया दैट इज
http.com इसमें लिस्ट ऑफ वेबसाइट्स होती
है पर्टिकुलर लिस्ट ऑफ वेबसाइट्स ऑन दैट
सर्वर ठीक है अब इसमें अलग-अलग चीजें भी
होती है अलाउड होस्ट होती है डिनाइड होस्ट
होस्टड अला हो ड नाई अलग-अलग कॉन्फिन होती
है जो कि आपको बेसिकली जब आप सर्वर की
कॉन्फिन वगैरह पढ़ेंगे तो उसमें आपको समझ
में आएगा ठीक है बट स्टिल अगर आपको पढ़ना
है तो आप अचे के कॉन्फिन फाइल को पढ़
लीजिएगा आपको समझ में आ जाएगा बट इससे
ज्यादा अभी आपको नहीं जानना है सिंपल सा
फंडा है कि अचे के कॉन्फिन फाइल्स में
लिस्ट ऑफ डोमस यहां पे आपको मिल जाती है
एंड फिर जब अचे को यह मेल फॉर्म्ड होस्ट
हेडर मिलता है मान लो यहां पे टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर ड आ ना
मिले यह तो टेक्निकल है बट यहां पे ये
एंट्री मिल जाए मान लो एंट्री क्या मिल
जाए यहां पे होस्ट में होस्ट में मान लो
यहां पे एंट्री मिल जाए bing.com
ये एक मलेशियन वेबसाइट है लेट्स सपोज दिस
इज अ मलेशियन वेबसाइट अब अचे को समझ में
नहीं आएगा उ लगेगा अरे यार ये कौन सी
रिक्वेस्ट ये किसके लिए रिक्वेस्ट आ गई है
ये कहां से रिक्वेस्ट आ गई है ये कौन सी
वेबसाइट के लिए डोमेन के लिए रिक्वेस्ट आ
गई है तो इस केस में जो कॉन्फिन फाइल की
पहली वर्चुअल होस्ट होती है वी होस्ट जो
पहली वर्चुअल होस्ट या डोमेन होता है उस
से आप इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं क्योंकि वो
रिक्वेस्ट पहले वर्चुअल होस्ट को अचे भेज
देता है यानी कि अचे जो है अचे जैसे ही
उसके पास आती है रिक्वेस्ट वो पहले जो
उसकी होस्ट होती है जो सर्वर होती है उसको
वो भेज देता है रिक्वेस्ट एंड उससे आप
इंटरेक्ट कर पाते हो बेसिकली तो हमेशा यह
पॉसिबल है कि जब भी कोई मिस कॉन्फिडो होती
है यहां पे तो वो पहले वर्चुअल होस्ट से
इंटरेक्ट आपको करवा देती है सिंपल
इंटरेक्ट कर पाते हो बस टट्स इट सिंपल सा
फंडा है ठीक है ये समझ में आपको आया इतना
बताइए
मुझे
अब समझ में आया कि नहीं आया लेट मी
नो
ओके ठीक है अब इसी पर आपका होस्ट हेडर
अटैक बेसिकली काम करता है इसी चीज पे अब
मान लो मैंने यहां पर मेरा ओरिजिनल
रिक्वेस्ट क्या है टेक्निकल नेविगेटर आ को
रहा है यहां प ठीक है अब मैंने इसमें चेंज
किया क्या चेंज किया मैंने यहां पर होस्ट
में bing.com कर दिया यह कर दिया bing.com
अब मैं इस रिक्वेस्ट को
जब एग्जीक्यूट करूंगा यहां पे एंड यहां पर
जब एग्जीक्यूट कर लूंगा तो यहां पर
रिस्पांस चेक करूंगा क्या रिस्पांस आ रहा
है 421 मिस मिस डायरेक्टेड रिक्वेस्ट यानी
कि यह रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो मिस डायरेक्टेड
है दिस इज नॉट द एक्चुअल रीडायरेक्शन जो
होनी चाहिए इसने डिटेक्ट किया कय क्लाउड
फेयर बेसिकली यूज हो रही है दे डिटेक्टेड
कि नहीं भाई य तो ये तो गलत रिक्वेस्ट गलत
डायरेक्शन अगर यह हो जाती रिक्वेस्ट इधर
सक्सेसफुली तो यहां पर हमारा यह पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट जैसे ही हम ओपन करते बंगड कॉ
हमारा ओपन हो जाता ी वड हैव ओपन बंगड कॉ
यानी कि हमारी टेक्निकल नेविगेटर आ
रीडायरेक्ट हो जाती बंगड कॉ प तो इसका
मतलब है यहां पर मैं अगर बताऊं यहां पर तो
होस्ट हेडर
इंजेक्शन
कैन लीड
टू ओपन रीडायरेक्शन वलने
बिलिटी यह ओपन रीडायरेक्शन वरे बिलिटी के
तरफ इशारा करता है एंड यू वुड बी फाइंडिंग
एंड यू कैन बी फा यू कैन बी फाइंडिंग लाइक
ओपन रीडायरेक्शन लेबिलिटी थ्रू होस्ट एंड
इंजेक्शन तो ये अब इसको फाइंड करने के
मल्टीपल तरीके हो सकते हैं बट इसके लिए वी
नीड सम टारगेट्स तो हम उसको यूज करेंगे बट
उसके पहले थोड़े और चीजें हैं हम उसको
समझेंगे पहले उसके बाद हम उसको यूज करेंगे
ठीक है
गट ओके कोई बात नहीं थोड़ा लेट हो गया कोई
कोई दिक्कत नहीं चलिए अब हम यहां पर उसके
लिए पोर्टस फिगर का जो लैब है उसको ओपन कर
लेते हैं ठीक है ना यह ओपन कर लेते हैं हा
एक चीज और देख लीजिए यहां पर मैं आपको
थोड़ा सा आईडिया दे देता हूं इस चीज का कि
होस्ट इंजेक्शन में क्याक होती है ओपन टी
के लिए कर सकता है य बेसिकली क्या होता है
इसका मतलब क्या
है इसका मतलब क्या हो जाता है
रीडायरेक्टिंग
विक्टिम टू अ हैकर ओन और
कंट्रोल्ड और
मलिस वेबसाइट्स ठीक है लाइक एनी फिशिंग
वेबसाइट लाइक एनी
फिशिंग और मैलवेयर वेबसाइट बस बस ए सिंपल
ठीक है समझ में आ गया अब सेकंड में आते
हैं सेकंड जो क्या होता है यहां पे अब
ध्यान दीजिएगा इधर थोड़ा सा ओपन डायरेक्शन
आपने देख लिया अब यहां पे सेकंड में होती
है एक वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग
अटैक वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग अटैक य ये हमारा
किससे होता है होस्ट सेडर इंजेक्शन से
पॉसिबल है ये वेब कैश ये मैं इसको इसको भी
डिस्कस करूंगा बताऊंगा क्या होता है ये
उसके बाद यहां पे पासवर्ड
रिसेट पॉइजनिंग अटैक भी होता है इससे
फोर्थ में आप एक्सएसएस अटैक भी इससे लॉन्च
कर सकते हैं एंड फिफ्थ में यहां पे आप
एसएसआरएफ भी लांच कर सकते हैं एसएसआरएफ पे
हम डिस्कस करेंगे बाद में लाइक जब
एसएसआरएफ वाली क्लास कर लेंगे ठीक है ना
तो ये हम डिस्कस करेंगे तो यह सारी चीजें
आप कर सकते हो एक होस्टड इंजेक्शन अटैक से
ठीक है तो जितना इंपैक्टफुल
आपका आपका जो फाइंडिंग होगा उतना ही
ज्यादा आपको रिवर्ड या बाउंट मिलने के
चांसेस है याद रखिएगा बग बाउंटीज के अंदर
में मैं आपको पहले ही बोल चुका हूं कि मैं
अगर आपको बग बाउंटीज के अंदर में इवन 100%
भी दे रहा हूं 100% भी बता रहा हूं आपको
200 पर उसको करके आना है समझ में आ रहा है
मैं क्या कहने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं 100%
भी मैं बता रहा हूं ना तबी वो 100% नहीं
होता है कोई भी नहीं करा सकता है इस बात
की मैं आपको गारंटी के साथ गारंटी दे सकता
हूं नोबडी कैन गिव यू 100% इन बग बाउंटीज
क्योंकि होता ही नहीं है कहां से देंगे
फिर भी आपको 200 पर करके आना है यानी कि
खुद से एक्सप्लोर करना है मैं एक चीज बता
रहा हूं उसके 10 10 तरीके हो सकते हैं अगर
मैं आपको एक चीज के पांच तरीके बताता हूं
छह तरीके बताता हूं सात तरीके बताता हूं
तो रिमेनिंग दो तरीका छह तरीका पांच तरीका
वो आपको देख के आना है आपको एक्सप्लोर
करना है प्रैक्टिस करनी है एंड इट विल मेक
यू डिफरेंट देन अदर्स जो कर लेंगे वो
डिफरेंट है बाकी लोग नॉर्मली जैसे होते
हैं वैसे हैं
चलिए अब यहां पे आते हैं होस्ट हेडर
अटैक्स के बारे में तो व्हाट इज एसटीटीपी
होस्ट हेडर मैं आपको पहले ही बता चुका हूं
सिंपल सा फंडा है यहां पे कि एसटीडीपी
होस्ट हेडर टैक्स एक्सप्लोइट वल्नरेबल
वेबसाइट्स वल्नरेबल वेबसाइट दैट हैंडल द
वैल्यू ऑफ द होस्ट हेडर इन एन अनसेफ वे इफ
द सर्वर इंपलीसिटली ट्रस्ट द होस्ट हेडर
मतलब सर्वर अगर होस्ट हेडर को बिना कुछ
सुने बिना कुछ समझे बिना कुछ एनालाइज किए
आंखें बंद करके अगर उस परे ट्रस्ट कर ले
रहा है यानी होस्ट सेडर पे यानी किस पे इस
पे इस पे यह होस्ट सेडर पे इस पे अगर
सर्वर ट्रस्ट कर लेता है कि अरे भाई कोई
बात नहीं आने दो जो है सो चलेगा तो फिर
वहां पर होडा इंजेक्शन अटैक होता है वो
पॉसिबल है एंड फेल्स टू वैलिडेट और स्केप
इट प्रॉपर्ली एंड अटैकर मे बी एबल टू यूज
दिस इनपुट टू इंजेक्ट हार्मफुल पेलोड्स
दैट मैनिपुलेट सर्वर साइड बिहेवियर अब अगर
मैंने इस पर्टिकुलर अब मान लो यार कि
सर्वर हमारे होस्ट हेडर को चेक ही नहीं कर
रहा या मान लो रिक्वेस्ट हेडर को वेरीफाई
नहीं कर रहा बहुत तरीके से एंड हमने इसमें
कुछ कुछ चीजें ऐड कर दी कुछ कुछ चीजें
चेंज कर दी मिस कॉन्फिन कर दी और उसको वो
पास कर रहा है एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा है सर्वर
तो हम तो सर्वर से जो चाहे सो एक्यूट करवा
सकते हैं हम बोलेंगे सर्वर को भैया य एक्स
का पेलोड है इसको एग्जीक्यूट करो एक्यूट
कर देगा एक्सस व पर आ जाएगी तो इस तरीके
चीज होती है समझ में आ रहा है इस तरीके
होती
है क्या बोल रहे हो भाई क्या क्वेश्चन है
आपका थोड़ा क्वेश्चन देखा
जाए सर इंपैक्ट क्या है सरबटी का वही तो
बताया विनय अभी जो आपको लिस्ट बताई मैं
आपको अभी दिखाता हूं सर यह बताओ जब वेब
टेस्टिंग करने जाओ उसका तरीका क्या है
कहां से स्टार्ट करें बग बाउंट की क्लासेस
पूरी देखो फाइट क्लब आपको सब समझ में आ
जाएगा बग बाउंट की क्लासेस पूरी देखिए यू
विल गेट टू नो
एवरीथिंग अच्छा हां तो यह तो हो गया और एक
और चीज है यहां पर मैं करता हूं गिट हब
टीम डि
फोनिक्स मैं आपको एक चीज दिखा
रिपोजिटरी व वाली कौन सी थी
यार नहीं नहीं जस्ट
सेकंड शमीम कौन सी रिपोजिटरी
थी व वाली रोड मैप
वाली
टीम डि फोनिक्स आई थिंक यहां
पे लेट मी सी
वनस इसमें तो शायद नहीं थी ये ओके ओके वो
दूसरे रेपो में ठीक है डिक्स प्रो में थी
वो ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है सॉरी
सॉरी हां तो यह वाली जो है एक रोड मैप
रिपोजिटरी है हमारा ही रिपोजिटरी है आप इस
पर आ सकते हैं राइट एंड दिस
रिपोजिटरी इज अमेजिंग इट इज मेंटेन बाय वन
ऑफ आवर टीम मेंबर शमीम सो अ ही हैज गिवन
एंड ही हैज पुट डाउन अ वेरी वेरी डिटेल
रिसोर्सेस हियर जहां पे आपको आके बेसिकली
क्या करना है कैसे करना है कैसे आगे बढ़ना
है बग बाउंटीज वगैरह में या साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में आपको यहां पे सब कुछ मिल
जाएगा एवरी डिटेल यहां पे आप आएंगे तो ठीक
है सो यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
एवरीथिंग यू विल बी गेटिंग तो इस पे आप आ
जाइएगा इसका मैं आपको लिंक भी जो है वो
शेयर ऑलरेडी शमीम ने किया हुआ है मैं वापस
से शेयर कर देता हूं यू कैन सी ठीक
है ओके अब इस ओपन डायरेक्शन वल बिलिटी का
जो जो इंपैक्ट है वो ये इस फॉर्म में आ
सकता है य ओपन डायरेक्शन के फॉर्म में
सॉरी होस्टड इंजेक्शन का जो इंपैक्ट है वो
ओपन डायरेक्शन के फॉर्म में आ सकता है वेब
कैशिंग पॉइजन के फॉर्म में आ सकता है
पासवर्ड रिसेट पॉइजनिंग में आ सकता है
एक्सएसएस के तरफ से आ सकता है एसएसआरएफ की
तरह आ सकता है ठीक है तो यह अब आपको समझ
में आ गया अब चलिए आते हैं यहां पे
अटैकर्स अटैक्स दैट इवॉल्व इंजेक्टिंग अ
पेलो डायरेक्टली इनटू द होस्ट हेडर आर
ऑफेन नोन एज होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन अटैक्स
तो वही हम करने वाले हैं सिंपल अब इसके
थ्रू आप क्या-क्या कर सकते हैं आप देख
सकते हैं वेब कैस्ट पॉइजनिंग बिजनेस लॉजिक
फ्लज राउटिंग बेस्ड एसएसआरएफ क्लासिक
सर्वर साइट वलन बिलिटी सच एज एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन तक आप इससे अचीव कर सकते हैं ठीक
है चलिए अब यहां पे हम ब बहुत सारी चीज
हैं विल ये आप खुद से पढ़िए मैं आपको
बोलूंगा रिकमेंड करूंगा होस्ट सेडर वाली
लैब को कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा इस वाले सेक्शन
को ठीक है ओके यहां पे अ कैसे आप होस्ट
सेडर से बच सकते हैं इंजेक्शन अटैक से ये
भी दिया हुआ है आप इसको जरूर पढ़िए इट विल
बी गुड अब इसके एक इंपैक्ट के ऊपर में आते
हैं इसके एक इंपैक्ट के ऊपर देखते हैं बट
उसके पहले हम इसका एक जो नॉर्मल सा
इंपैक्ट है जो नॉर्मल इंपैक्ट है ओपन
रीडायरेक्शन ये वाली एंड वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग
ये वाली हम देख लेते हैं देखो ओपन
डायरेक्शन का तो आपको पता ही है मैंने
आपको यहां पे सिंपल सा बता दिया कि यहां
पे होस्ट को चेंज करो या एक अलग से रेफरर
हेडर डालो उसमें एक मलेशियन होस्ट डालो या
तो एक्स फॉरवर्ड होस्ट एक हेडर होता है
उसको डालो व एंड अगर फिर रीडायरेक्ट हो
रहा है उसके थ्रू भी अगर ये सारी चीजों के
साथ ये रीडायरेक्शन हो रही है देन दैट
देयर इज अ अ क्या देयर इज अ ओपन अ होस्टड
इंजेक्शन अटैक ठीक है ओपन डायरेक्शन
होस्टड इंजेक्शन तो अब चलिए इसमें हम एक
टारगेट पहले चूज कर लेते हैं एक जस्ट
टेस्टिंग करते हैं ठीक है जस्ट टेस्टिंग
तो हम क्या करते हैं टेस्टिंग के लिए वी
आर गोइंग टू यूज ओपन बग बाउटी वेबसाइट ठीक
है चलिए ओपन बग बाउटी पर आते
हैं यहां पर हम आ चुके हैं कुछ अभी एक
टारगेट चूज करेंगे राइट तो यहां फिलहाल के
लिए मैं यह सारी चीज बंद कर देता हूं इट्स
नॉट
रिकवा कैसे करना है क्या करना है वो मैं
आपको थोड़ा रहा हूं ठीक है तो मैं कोई सा
भी एक एक प्रोग्राम ले लेता हूं रिसेंटली
स्टार्टेड प्रोग्राम ले लेते हैं जैसे
कंटेंट ड एई यह वाली प्रोग्राम ले लेते
केंट ड ए कौन
साय हां तो अब इनके जितने भी डोमेन सब
डोमेन है सारे इन स्कोप है तो ट्स अ वेरी
ग्रेट थिंग तो आपको हर डोमेन हर सब डोमेन
पर ट्राई करना हर एक यूआरएल पर ट्राई करना
है जिस जो कि टू एक्सेसेस या थ्री एक्सेस
जो स्टेटस कोड्स देते हैं जो कि एसटीडीपी
स्टेटस
कोड टू एक्सेस वाले होते हैं और थ्री
एक्सस वाले होते हैं रीडायरेक्ट वाले या
ओके वाले ठीक है तो केंट ड ए ये वाली ओपन
कर लेते हैं
भैया चलो इसको ओपन कर लिया कंटेंड ए वाली
ठीक है चलिए अब मैं मुझे इसको मैं क्या
करूंगा इसको इंटरसेप्ट करके एक बार कर
लेता हूं प्रॉक्सी चलता हूं इंटरसेप्ट ऑन
कर लेता हूं मैं यहां पे इसको मैं रीलोड
करता हूं मेरे को यहां पे आ जाएगा इस वाले
में फॉरवर्ड करता हूं फॉरवर्ड कर देता हूं
ये कंटेंट ड ए आ चुका है इसको मैं राइट
क्लिक करता हूं एंड एंड इसको मैं कर देता
हूं सेंड टू रिपीटर भी एंड राइट क्लिक
करके सेंड टू स्पाइडर ठीक है स्पाइडर में
मैं इसको भेज देता हूं वुड यू लाइक टू
मॉडिफाई यस इ स्कोप में इंक्लूड कर लेते
हैं
यस ओके यस कर देते हैं ठीक है बस
इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर देते हैं अब स्पाइडरिंग
में आप चलेंगे तो ऑलरेडी जो है वो स्पाइडर
हो रही होगी एंड यहां टारगेट प चलके स्कोप
में आपको ये कंटेंट एआई वाला जो स्कोप है
य ऐड हो चुका है बट स्कोप को थोड़ा सा
हमें यहां पर मॉडिफाई करना पड़ेगा कंटेंट
ड ए ओनली है ना कंटेंड ए यह वाली चीज
डालते हैं इसको मैं यहां पे हटा देता हूं
एंड यहां पे मैं ओके कर देता हूं ठीक है
केंड ए टारगेट पे चल देते हैं यहां पे
साइट मैप पे यहां पे फिल्टर आउट लगा देते
हैं शो ओनली इन स्कोप आइटम्स तो कंटेंट ड
ए वाली जो आपकी टारगेट है वो आ जाएगी ओनली
सो जस्ट वेट ये आ चुका है यहां पे ट्स इट
इसको मैं थोड़ा सा
लेबोरेटरी आई थिंक स्पाइडर रही होगी है तो
स्पाइडरिंग हमने स्टार्ट कर दिया ठीक है
हम सारे जो यूरल है सबके लिए
ओके ओके तो क्या भाई क्या बातें हो रही है
आप लोगों
की
ओके सर आपकी ट्रेनिंग से बहुत सीखने को
मिल रहा है एंड कंसिस्टेंसी भी मेंटेन कर
पा रहा हूं ब्रेक के कारण ठीक है थैंक यू
सो मच फॉर योर वर्ल्ड क्लास कंटेंट मैं भी
मैं अभी डे 13 में जल्दी कैच अप कर लूंगा
ओके ग्रेट अंकित राज ट्स ग्रेट इफ यू आर
लाइकिंग दिस एंड इफ यू आर गेटिंग बेनिफिट
फ्रॉम दिस ठीक है तो हम यहां पर आ चुके
हैं केंट ड ए पे सो नाउ हमें स्टेटस कोड
देखने है जो 200 वाले हैं और जो 300 वाले
स्टेटस कोड्स है तो 200 वाले हैं सारे ये
सारे 200 200 200 वाले हैं 300 वाले भी है
क्या कोई देख लेते हैं हां ये वाले भी है
300 वाले भी है 307 302 ये है किसी प भी
जा सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है तो
मैं क्या करता हूं मैंने यहां पे
स्पाइडरिंग चालू कर दिया है स्पाइडरिंग
अभी भी हो रही है चलिए होने देते हैं इसको
अब व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू आई एम गोइंग
टू चूज द टारगेट जैसे मैं इसका मेन जो पाथ
है उसी को यूज कर लेता हूं एंड इसको
रिपीटर को भेज देता हूं मैं यहां प रिपीटर
प मैंने ऑलरेडी ये वाला स्लैश भेज दिया
हुआ है
शायद या ठीक है इसको कर लेते हैं मैं यहां
पे अब यहां पे हम होस्ट इंजेक्शन के
लिए करेंगे सो व्ट वी आर गोइंग टू डू
होस्ट में कंटेंट ड ए है ना यहां पर तो हम
इसको मल्टीपल तरीके से कर सकते हैं पहला
सबसे तरीका है होस्ट को ही चेंज कर दो एंड
एक मलिस होस्ट यानी कि जैसे फिलहाल के लिए
बड क में डाल देता हूं ब क ठीक
है जो हमारा रियल टारगेट था कंटेंट डई
इसको हमने चेंज करके किया बड क अब मैं य
गो पर क्लिक करता
हूं गो पर जैसे ही मैंने क्लिक किया य पर
आप देख सकते मिस डायरेक्टेड रिक्वेस्ट आ
रही है ठीक है ना एंड दिस मिस डायरेक्टेड
fly.com से आ रही है दे आर यूजिंग अ
सीडीएन अ बेसिकली नोन एज fly.com तो ये
fly.com को यूज कर रहे हैं तो इन्होंने ये
चीज भेजी हुई है कि भैया ये मिस डी
डायरेक्ट है ऐसे नहीं काम चलेगा ठीक है बस
दैट्ची बात है दिस इज नॉट करेंटली वर्किंग
ठीक है तो मैं क्या करता हूं मैं यहां
पे जो पहले वाला हमारा रिक्वेस्ट था
bing.com यही वाला लान देते हैं फिलहाल
केलिए मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता
हूं मैं टारगेट पर चलता हूं मैं इस वाले
को ले लेता हूं राइट क्लिक करता हूं एंड
यहां पर मैं कर देता हूं सेंड टू रिपीटर
थैंक यू अंकित
राज फॉर योर सुपर चैट यहां पर चलते हैं अब
कंटेंड को यहां पर मैं कर देता हूं होस्ट
में
www.bing.com या डायरेक्टली b.com कर
दीजिए गो पे क्लिक करते हैं अगर गो पर
क्लिक करने के बाद यहां पर कुछ रिस्पांस
ऐसा आता है जो bing.com को कंटेन करता है
तो हो सकता है यहां ओपन डायरेक्शन हो बट
यहां फिलहाल कुछ भी नहीं आ रहा चलिए कोई
बात नहीं यहां प मैं सिंपल bing.com एक
बार टाइप कर लेता
हूं ओके मिस रीडायरेक्ट आ रहा है यहां पे
ट्स ग्रेट ठीक है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
कुछ भी नहीं यहां पे मैं कंट्रोल जड कर
देता हूं यहां पे मैं प्रीवियस जो हमारी
ओरिजिनल रिक्वेस्ट उस पर आ जाता है कंट अब
यहां पे एक चीज और कर सकते हैं होस्ट तो
हमारा कंटेंट ड एई ही है बस सिंपल अब यहां
पर मैं क्या कर देता हूं यहां पर एक हेडर
डालता हूं एक्
फॉरवार्डेड फॉरवर्ड होस्ट मैं ये डाल देता
हूं एक्स फॉरवर्ड होस्ट अब इसमें मैं
bing.com डाल देता हूं b.com कई बार यह जो
है ना होस्ट एंट्रीज को कई बार चेंज कर
देता होस्ट की रीडायरेक्शन को एक बार चेंज
कर देता है लाइक जैसे होस्ट के कंटेंट को
चेंज कर देता है ठीक है फोर्सफुली तो एक्स
फॉरवर्ड होस्ट एक आपका हेडर है इसको हम
यूज कर सकते हैं गो प क्लिक कर सकते हैं
एंड जैसे ही मैंने ग्लो प क्लिक किया गाइस
आपको यहां पर दिख रहा होगा कि ये 200 ओ के
आ रहा है हमारा अभी फिलहाल के लिए कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है अब यहां पर हम देखेंगे कि
लाइक कुछ हुआ है क्या य आप देखिए 200 ओके
यहां पे एंड यर लेट्स सी इफ देर इ
bing.com ब क कहीं प कुछ है ब क नहीं कहीं
ब क नहीं है इसका मतलब दिस इ नॉट
रीडायरेक्टेड एंड दिस इ नॉट वल्नरेबल
काइंड ऑफ थिंग ठीक है तो चलिए हमने तो ये
चेक कर लिया ट्स ग्रेट अब अब हम क्या कर
देते हैं एक्स फॉरवर्ड होस्टड होस्ट यहां
प ये चीज आ गई है हमारी अब हम यहां प क्या
करेंगे देखो यहां प अब होस्ट
में ठीक है होस्ट में हमें क्या करना है
ना bing.com डालना है bing.com एंड एक्स
फॉरवर्ड होस्ट में इसका ओरिजिनल डालना है
क्या
कंटेंट ए ये डालते कंट ड आई थिंक यही है
हमारा लेट्स सी के ओ एन टीई एन टी ठीक है
कंट अब इसको मैं गो पे क्लिक करता हूं
अगेन मिस रीडायरेक्टेड आ रहा है यहां पे
फास्टली को यूज कर रही है तो अगेन यहां पे
ये सेम चीज आ रही है तो कोई कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है अब हम य पर एक और हेडर डाल सकते
हैं मैं य कंट्रोल जड करके ओरिजनल प आ
जाता हूं क मैं य रेफरल हेडर ड देता हू
रेफरर हेडर डाल देता हूं ठीक है वी विल बी
यूजिंग द रेफरर हेडर तो मैं रेफरर हेडर
डलता हूं य प आई थंक रेफरर हेडर की
स्पेलिंग सही है
क्या स्पेलिंग देख लेते
हैं हा जी आरई एफ आरई ठीक है रेफरल हेडर
में मैं य पर बड क डाल
देता ओके क्लिक ऑन गो एंड लेटस सी बैड
रिक्वेस्ट ये रिक्वेस्ट बैड रिक्वेस्ट आ
रही है तो इट्स डन ये नहीं काम कर र है य
पे अब होस्ट में मैं यहां प bing.com डाल
देता हूं अगेन होस्ट में भी bing.com
रेफरल में b.com बैड रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है
चलिए तो दिस इज काइंड ऑफ नॉट वल्नरेबल ऐसा
हम मान सकते हैं बट इसके हमारे पास टारगेट
और भी बहुत सारे हैं एक सिर्फ यही टारगेट
नहीं ठीक है सो लेट्स सी हम कोई एक और
टारगेट ले लेते हैं जैसे कि यह एक टारगेट
है रेड सेंड टू रिपीटर रिपीटर चलते य प
एंड यहां पर होस्ट कंट आ रहा है गो प
क्लिक करते हैं इट विल बी गिविंग द 200
ओके ठीक है टस टोटली फाइन एंड अब हम क्या
कर देते य प कंटेंट ड ए
पे एक् फॉरवर्ड होस्ट यूज करना है ना अपने
को कंटेंट ड एई यहां से जो है इसको हम
बंगड क कर लेते हैं बड कॉ ए लेट्स क्लिक
ऑन द गो अगेन मिस डायरेक्टेड हो रहा है य
प अगेन
एक्स फॉरवर्ड फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट एंड यहां
पे हम डाल देते
हैं कंटेंट ड एई ठीक है अब यहां पे गो प
क्लिक कर देते हैं अगेन मिस्ट तो ये यहां
पे दिस इज नॉट वर्किंग ओबवियसली दिस कैन
बी दिस हैज बीन रिजॉल्वड काइंड ऑफ ऐसा आप
मान सकते हैं चलिए और भी देख लेते हैं
अबाउट सेंड टू
रिपीटर यहां पे एंड यहां रेफरल हेडर जो है
ये आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे रेफरल हेडर
ये वाली जो यह दी हुई है तो रेफरर को हम
यहां पर चेंज कर देते हैं रेफरल को हम कर
देते हैं bing.com पहले पहले ओनली रेफरल
हेडर को चेंज करते हैं गो प क्लिक करते
हैं 200 ओके आ रहा है यहां पे लेट्स टाइप
bing.com bing.com इज देयर इन bing.com नो
नो नो bing.com नहीं है यहां पे कोई बात
नहीं होस्ट जो है ना होस्ट इसको यही रहने
देते हैं
एक्स
फॉरवर्ड एक्स
फॉरवर्ड होस्ट इसको करते हैं यहां पे
bing.com
तो हमने किया एक्स फॉर वर्डेड होस्ट
ठीक है एक्स फ होस्ट डाल दिया हमने ब क
इसको गो पर क्लिक करते लेट सी 200 ओके आ
रहा है य देख लेते
ब बंग आ रहा है क्या कहीं नहीं आ रहा ब ब
ब ब
कॉ दे नो ब क रिफ्लेक्टिंग र सो इट माइट
बी न वल्नरेबल तो इस तरीके से आपको चेक
करना है चलिए और भी चेक कर लेते हैं और भी
पॉइंट एंट्री पॉइंट चेक करेंगे जैसे
की यह वाली चेक करते हैं सेंड टू रिपीटर
रिपीटर प चलते हैं य प अभी पासवर्ड रिसेट
पॉ आएंगे उसम भी मजा आएगा आपको बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है वो ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं लेट हो तो क्या दिक्कत है यार एंड
मैं आज की क्लास थोड़ा थोड़ा शॉर्ट रखूंगा
क्योंकि मेरे को अंदर से अच्छा फील कुछ हो
नहीं रहा है अभी
एंड एंड एंड थोड़ा सा वैसे भी आईज में भी
थोड़ी सी जलन टाइप हो रही है तो मैं थोड़ी
क्लासेस छोटी रखूंगा ठीक है आज की क्लास
तो प्लीज डोंट माइंड ऑफ
दैट ठीक है तो यहां पर होस्ट हमारा कंट डई
है इसको हम अगेन चेंज करते हैं यहां पे
b.com कर लेते हैं यहां पे एंड गो पे
क्लिक करते हैं अगेन दिस इज मिक्स
रीडायरेक्ट वाली चीज आ रही है तो इसको हम
एज अ टारगेट फिलहाल के लिए हटा देते हैं
ठीक है व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू हम इसको
रिमूव कर देते हैं स्कोप से एंड साइट मैप
हम यहां पे आते हैं एंड सो इन स्कोप आइटम
को हटा देते हैं या रि इनेबल कर देते हैं
ट्स इट चलिए अब हम कोई एक और टारगेट को
लेके कोई एक दूसरे टारगेट पे चलते हैं
लेट्स गो टू सम अदर टारगेट ठीक है हां
इसके सब डोमेंस भी है आपके स्कोप में तो
आप इनके सब डोमस प भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं सिर्फ डोमेन प नहीं करना इनके सब डोमस
फाइंड कीजिए सब डोमेन फाइंड करना आपके लिए
कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है दो मिनट आपको लगेगा
सब डोमेन फाइंड करने में राइट तो जस्ट
अ जस्ट सब डोमेन फाइंड कीजिए एंड इस पे
सेम टाइप का सेम टाइप की आप चीजें करना है
आपको जो चीजें मैंने आपको बताई सेम चीज
आपको टाइप करनी है ठीक है आपको य ट्राई
करना है
चलिए इस पे चलते हैं मोटर स्टेट ये क्या
क्या है इस पे चलते हैं हां ये कौन सी है
बीके डायरेक्ट कुछ है ऐसे वेबसाइट है चलो
इसको ओपन कर लेते
हैं स्पैम मत करो यार आज मतलब मजा नहीं आ
रहा फिर स्पैम करोगे तो फिर तो हटाना
पड़ेगा
आपको ओके मैं यहां पर आपको टाइम आउट में
डाल रहा हूं पी डब्लू मोशन आपके स्पैम के
लिए टेंशन मत लीजिए आप फिर से जवाइन कर
लीजिएगा बाद में बट अभी 30 मिनट के लिए
आपको 10 मिनट के लिए टाइम आउट डाल देता
हूं ठीक है आप यहां मैसेज नहीं कर पाएंगे
ओके हा जी तो यह हटा देते
इसको अब यह कुकीज वाली है तो यह हमारा
टारगेट हो जाता है तो इसको हम यहां पर
कैप्चर कर लेते एक बार प्रॉक्सी इंटरसेप्ट
ऑन कर लेते हैं लेट्स रीलोड
ट लेट्स फॉरवर्ड इट फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड
फॉरवर्ड य रहा तो इसको राइट क्लिक करते
हैं एंड सेंड
टू स्पाइडर कर देते हैं स्कोप में ऐड कर
देते हैं यस कर देते हैं ट्स इट तो
स्पाइडर पर चलते
हैं यहां पर स्पाइडरिंग यहां पर आप चलते
टारगेट प स्कोप में ऐड हो चुका है हमारा
यह वाला तो साइड में प चलके यहां पर सो
ओनली इन स्कोप आइटम्स कर देते
हैं ठीक है ओनली इन स्कोप आइटम्स हमने कर
दिया य
प ठीक है तो आ गया यहां प अब हम इस पर
स्पाइडर इसको ऑलरेडी हमने शायद किया हुआ
था ठीक है फिर से कर दिया मैंने एक बार तो
इसको हम स्पाइडर कर देते हैं ठीक है वी आर
स्पाइडरिंग इट एंड वी कैन सी
हियर अ ल लॉट ऑफ 200 रिक्वेस्ट राइट तो
इसके हम मेन डोमेन पे चलते हैं राइट क्लिक
करके सेंड टू रिपीटर पे क्लिक करते हैं
रिपीटर पे चलते हैं यहां पे ये रही होस्ट
यहां पे गो पे क्लिक करते हैं दिस विल गिव
यू 200 ओके
दैट्ची एंड यहां पे 403 फॉर बिन आ रही है
क्लाउड फ्रंट यूज कर रही है ट्स वई इट्स
गिविंग 403 फॉर बिडेन ठीक है चलिए अच्छी
बात है यहां पे अब यहां पर हम यहां पर कर
देते हैं एक्स फॉर वडेड होस्ट एंड एक्स
फॉर वर्डेड होस्ट में यहां पर हम दे देते
हैं जो हमारी रियल वेबसाइट है वो दे देते
हैं ठीक है यह वाली वेबसाइट जो हमारी है
यही दे देते हैं
डड ब्रोड डायरेक्ट ब्रोड ट जो भी है उसको
पढ़ लीजिए आप गो पे क्लिक करते हैं इसको
ट्राई करते हैं अगेन फॉर बिडेन है यहां पे
अगेन कोई बात नहीं मैं होस्ट में सेम रहने
देता हूं इसको इंटरचेंज कर लेते हैं एंड
एक्स फॉरवर्ड में हम अपनी जो मशियल
वेबसाइट है फिलहाल के लिए bing.com अब ये
bing.com ना कोई भी मलेशियन वेबसाइट हो
सकते हैं जो हैकर कंट्रोल हो जरूरी नहीं
bing.com ये तो हमें अपने वो दिखाने के
लिए पीओ में ये हमने डाला है bing.com अगर
आपकी अपनी वेबसाइट है जिस परे आपने एक
फिशिंग पेज होस्ट कर रखा है या कोई
मलेशियन पेज हो होस्ट कर रखा है या कोई
क्राफ्टेड पेज है आपके पास आप उसका यहां
पर डाल सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक
है ओके तो यहां प हम गो प क्लिक करते हैं
लेट्स सी येय 200 ओके आ तो रहा है तो बिंग
को सर्च कर लेते हैं बंगड कॉ इज इट
रिफ्लेक्टिंग नो इट्स नॉट देयर कोई बात
नहीं यहां पर हम एक रेफरल जो हेडर है ना
यह वाली रेफरल हेडर इसको भी चेंज करके
देखेंगे तो रेफरल हेडर में हम bing.com
डाल देते हैं एंड जस्ट गो लेट्स सी 200
ओके
ग्रेट
इज देयर बिंग बंग नहीं
है कोई बात नहीं रेफर में हमने कर दि एक्स
फॉर्डेड होस्ट को हम हटा देते हैं लेट्स
रिमूव इट देन प्लेस गो देन सर्च बंग एंड
अन नॉट मैचिंग राइट कोई मैच नहीं हो रहा
है चलिए कोई बात नहीं तो यहां पर भी आपका
कुछ ऐसा कुछ हमारा मैचिंग नहीं आ रहा यहां
पर भी देर इ नो सच थिंग्स बट स्टिल हमारे
पास एक टारगेट नहीं है देरर मल्टीपल
टारगेट्स ट वी कैन ट्राई ऑन मल्टीपल
टारगेट जहां हम ट्रा न कर सकते जैसे यहां
प एपीआई वाली एक पाथ है तो इसको हम रिपीटर
पर ले जाते हैं यहां पर टर एंड य इसको
रिक्वेस्ट कर एपीआई वाली को चलिए अच्छी
बात है यहां पर सो लेट्स ट्राई टू चेंज द
होस्ट
यर लेट्स ट्राई टू चेंज
डडड क एंड यह फर बिन ही आ रहा है य पर
चलिए अच्छी बात है ओके लेटस ट्राई टू चेंज
सम अर
पैरामीटर रि चलते कोई और
पाथ है उस पर चलते हैं यहां पर चलते हैंड
बड
कॉ गो पर क्लिक कर लेते हैं अगेन फॉर बिन
य प अगेन सेम फॉर बिन आ रही है तो मे बी
इट्स नॉट वल्नरेबल ऐसा हो सकता है चलिए तो
यहां पर आपको वैसे ही टारगेट ूज करने है
जो भी आपको टारगेट चाहिए जो भी आपको करने
है यूज करने है आप कर सकते हैं हम कोई से
भी टारगेट यूज कर रहे हैं फिलहाल के लिए
लेट्स
सी नथिंग यर नथिंग ओके लेट्स ओपन दिस
वन
ओके यहां हमने ओपन कर लिया ये कौन सी है
भाई मोटर स्टेट मोटर स्टेट ठीक है भाई अ
मैं यहां पे प्रॉक्सी पे इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन
कर देता हूं एंड यहां पे मैं इसको रीलोड
कर लेता हूं एंड लेट्स कैप्चर दिस
पर्टिकुलर थिंग सेंड इ टू स्पाइडर स्कोप
में डाल देते हैं अच्छी बात है इसको बंद
कर देते हैं टारगेट पे चलते हैं यहां पे
स्कोप
से स्कोप से इसको हटा देते हैं पहले जो
पहला हम हटागे था इसको रहने देते हैं ओनली
तो हमारा यह चीज आ चुका है हम इस पे
स्पाइडर कर देते हैं स्पाइडर हमारा हो रहा
है यहां
पे स्पाइडर हो रही है ये चीज एंड ट्स इट
ठीक है सो वी गेट अ मेनी यूआरएल यहां पे
बहुत सारे यूआरएल हमारे पास आ चुके हैं
कोई से भी एक यूआरएल को उठा लेते हैं जैसे
पहला वाला जो हमारा मेन जो हमारा पाथ है
उसी को उठा लेते हैं सेंड टू रिपीटर मार
देते हैं रिपीटर प चलते हैं एंड यहां पर
मैं गो प क्लिक कर देता हूं इट इज गिविंग
द रिस्पांस परफेक्ट वे अब यहां पे मैं
होस्ट को चेंज करता हूं पहले तो यह देखता
हूं इसका रिस्पांस क्या आ रहा है
b.com गो प क्लिक करते हैं अगेन 404 नॉट
फाउंड आ रहा है यहां पे ट्स गुड होस्ट को
हम यहां पे कंट्रोल जड करके जो पहले था
हमारा होस्ट उसी को रखते हैं एंड यहां पे
एक्स फॉर वडेड होस्ट जो है इसको इसको हम
कर देते हैं क्या बि
क एक्स फॉर वडेड होस्ट ब कॉ कि हमने गो प
क्लिक किया लेटस सी 200 ओके ठीक है यहां प
बिंग देख लेते बिंग है क्या कहीं प नहीं ब
य प कहीं प कुछ नहीं है रिक्ट नहीं हो रहा
तो इट्स नॉट वर्किंग रेफरल हेडर देखते य
है कि नहीं य प इस दे रेफरल
हेडर नो सो लेट्स डू वन थिंग होस्ट को हम
चेंज करते हैं होस्ट को हम यहां पे एक्स
फॉर्डेड में होस्ट रख देते हैं मेन और
यहां पर हम बंगड कॉ डाल देते हैं एंड
लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग अगेन नॉट फंडेड
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं य पे रेफरल हेडर डाल
देते
हैं बंगड कॉम नॉट अवेलेबल यहां पे एक्स
फॉरवर्ड को रिमूव एक्स फॉरवार्डेड का जो
हमारा मेन जो हमारी डोमेन है इसको हम
होस्ट में डाल देते हैं अगेन एंड एक्स
फॉरवर्ड को वी आर गोइंग टू रिमूव इट एंड
देन ओनली रेफरर के साथ जाते हैं लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग ओके लेट्स टाइप बिंग
बिंग ओके नहीं नहीं आया यहां पे सो वी आर
नॉट गेटिंग इट राइट सो हमें यहां पे भी
कुछ यहां पे नहीं मिला है तो आपको इस दिस
वे यू हैव टू जस्ट कीप ऑन ट्राइब ट्राई
आउट करते रहना है अगर आपको कहीं पे कुछ
मिलता है दैट इज अन ओपन डायरेक्शन वलने
बिलिटी और आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
अ कि ओपन डायरेक्ट दे आर एक्सेप्टिंग ठीक
है ओपन डायरेक्ट आप इसको रिपोर्ट कर सकते
हैं अगर आपके पास इस तरीके की चीजें आती
है ठीक है पहला च यह चीज हो गया एक और कोई
टारगेट हम उठा लेते हैं कोई सा भी एक
टारगेट ले लेते हैं
[संगीत]
अ लेट्स स एंड यहां
पे अ फिक्स्ड वाली जो है ना इसमें देखते
हैं इस पे चलते हैं यह वाली डोमेन पे चलते
हैं
लेट्स गो टू
दिस दिस डोमेन लेट्स ओपन
इट डॉट
एलय ओके इटस ओपनिंग तो ओपन हो चुका है
यहां
पर तो यहां पर चलते हैं प्रॉक्सी पे
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर देते हैं एंड लेट्स
रीलोड इट सो हेयर वी गॉट फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड
फॉरवर्ड
फॉरवर्ड ओके कहां गया भैया
हमारा अबे हमारी टारगेट कहां
गई ये हो क्या रहा
है ओके चलो मैं वापस से रीलोड करता हूं
यहां पे इंटरसेप्ट अरे
या इंटरसेप्ट को मैं यहां पर ऑन कर देता
हूं रीलोड इट यह रहा सेंड टू स्पाइडर कर
देते हैं स्कोप में ऐड कर देते हैं
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते हैं टारगेट प आ
जाते हैं स्कोप में आके मोटर स्टेट वाली
को रिमूव कर देते हैं इसकी जरूरत नहीं है
साइड मै आ जाते हैं यहां पर स्पाइडर कर
देते इसको इट इज गेटिंग स्टार्टेड
राइट डीजे कहां गया पता नहीं डीजे कहां
गया
हाउ आर यू सर आईम नॉट ट गुड करेंटली बट
आईम गुड थैंक यू तो चलिए यह आ गया हमारे
पास इवेंट्स वाले पर हम चलते हैं यह 200
है ना राइट क्लिक करते हैं सेंड टू रिपीटर
पर क्लिक करते हैं रिपीटर ब जाते
हैं होस्ट को हम यहां पर
www.bing.com करते हैं यहां पर एंड यहां
पर गो पर क्लिक कर देते हैं गो प क्लिक
करते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इ द रिस्पांस वी आर
गेटिंग 200 के आ रहा है य पर बंगड
कॉ इट्स
रिफ्लेक्टिंग ना कोई बिंग तो नहीं आ रहा
बट य कोई एरर भी नहीं आ रही है सो वी कैन
ट्रा ट्राई न ऑन यहां पर बंगड कॉ डालते
हैं गो प क्लिक करते हैं लेटस सर्च फॉर
एनी बंग ब ब सो बंग यहां पर कुछ आया नहीं
बी आई एन जी
नहीं यहां पर
हम बड क तो रहने देते हैं यहां प एक्स
फॉरवर्ड होस्ट में यहां डाल देते
हैं जो हमारा टारगेट
है नेटर पकड एय चलिए भाई यही डाल देते
हैं नेटर पार्क डट
एलय एंड गो पर क्लिक करते हैं लेटस इ य आर
गेटिंग समथिंग ओके ब कुछ नहीं मिला हमें
अब हम नेट पकड जो वलू है इसको यहां डाल
देते हैं होस्ट में एंड नीचे जो है हम
bing.com डाल देते हैं गो पे क्लिक करते
हैं लेटस सी ये आ ये है मूव्ड परमानेंटली
301 मूव्ड परमानेंटली आ रहा है गाइज यहां
पे जब हमने एक्स फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट यूज
किया bing.com के लिए तो एक्चुअली दिस इज
अ गुड थिंग अगर ऐसा कुछ आपके पास आता है
तो इट्स अ गुड थिंग ये हो सकता है
रीडायरेक्ट कर दे आपको bing.com पे ये भी
याद रखिएगा ये पॉसिबली हो सकता है इट कैन
बी रीडायरेक्टिंग टू bing.com होगा नहीं
अभी देख लेते फॉलो डायरेक्शन आपको करना है
लेट्स सी व्ट इ
हैपनिंग ओके लेट्स टाइप बंग ओट सो इट्स
नॉट
एक्चुअली रीडायरेक्टिंग बट ठीक है एक बार
क्या करते हैं ना गो बैक मैं बैक प चलता
हूं यहां प एंड इसको मैं राइट क्लिक करके
शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर करता हूं मैं कॉपी
कर लेता हूं ए लेट्स एग्जीक्यूट इट इन
ब्राउजर लेटस सी व्ट इ
हैपनिंग
ओके ओके सो ठीक है यहां पर यह रिस्पांस आ
रही है मूव परमानेंटली का मैं यहां पर मूव
कर देता हूं यहां
पर इसका एक बार देख लेते य रिस्प भी देख
लेते हैं क्या है
य तो य इस तरह की चीज आई ना जब कभी की
मूव्ड परमानेंटली ऐसे 301 म इसका मतलब कुछ
ना कुछ य चक्कर चल रहा है कुछ ना कुछ हो
रहा है य प तो पॉसिबली आपका यहां पर कुछ
मिल सकता है ऐसा हो तो बढ़िया है यहां
रेफरल हेडर को भी चेंज करता हूं लेट्स
चेंज रेफरल हेडर टू बंग
कम लेट्स सी वट इ
हैपनिंग अगेन मूव्ड
परमानेंटली फॉलो
रीडायरेक्शन एंड लेट्स सी बंगड क है कि
नहीं नहीं है यहां यहां प भी नहीं है बट
स्टिल इट्स गिविंग समथिंग कि हां भाई मे
बी पॉसिबली हो सकता है ये तो अब यहां पे
एक और काम करेंगे यहां जो होस्ट है ना
होस्ट आपका यह वाला तो इसको भी मैं
bing.com करता हूं फिर से बंगड कम एंड
इसको मैं गो प क्लिक करता हूं लेट्स सी
व्ट इज
हैपनिंग ओके इस बार रीडायरेक्शन फॉलो तो
नहीं हुआ बट कोई फायदा हमें नहीं मिलता
नहीं मिला हम यहां
प तो मैं यहां पर पहले जैसे कर देता हूं
अब मैं एक काम करता हूं यहां पे डबल होस्ट
कर देता हूं होस्ट अ ठीक है मैंने एक
होस्ट किया एंड यहां अगेन होस्ट करके मैं
बिंग ड कॉ डालता हूं डबल होस्ट यहां पे
यूज करेंगे गो पे क्लिक करेंगे लेट्स सी
बैड रिक्वेस्ट आ रही
है
ओके ओके मैं यहां
पे अ नेचर पार्क यह वाली थी हमारी बैक कर
लेते हैं बैक कर लेते हैं बैक कर लेते हैं
यह वाली ओरिजिनल थी हमारी होस्ट bing.com
था हमारा एंड इसके भी पहले हमारा होस्ट जो
था वो नेचर पार्क था ठीक
है नेचर पार्क है जो भी बोल लो अब यहां प
ना होस्ट में नेचर पार्क भी दे देते हैं
एंड होस्ट में हम यहां पर बिड कॉ भी दे
देते डबल होस्ट यूज कर लेते हैं ऐसा भी आप
कर सकते हैं ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं बायपास
करने के लिए 200 बै 400 बैड रिक्वेस्ट आ
रही है ब ठीक है कोई बात नहीं य पर एक्स
फॉर वर्डेड मैंने बोला ना कि यह बग
बाउंटीज है ठीक
है अच्छा रुक
जाओ यह बग बाउंटीज है बक बाउंटीज में
जितनी तरह के मेथी को यूज करेंगे जितना आप
ट्राई करेंगे अलग-अलग चीज को करने का उतना
आपका जो माइंड है ना ओपन होगा य पर एक
फॉरवर्ड होस्ट में भी मैं डाल देता हूं ब
क एंड लेट्स
सी
नहीं नहीं हो रहा य अब यहां पर मैं क्या
कर देता
हूं एक्स फॉरवर्ड में बिंग ना करके रियल
होस्ट डाल देता हूं जो हमारा रियल होस्ट
है उसको डाल
देता
गो नहीं सो इट्स नॉट एक्चुअली वर्किंग ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं वर्क नहीं कर रहा कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है हम
दूसरे टारगेट को यूज कर सकते हैं लेट्स
चेक सम
चलो ओ 30 वा ले लेते य वा लेते ठीक है 30
वाला या फिर यह ले लेते हैं कोई सा भी ले
लो पेज
आईडी सेंड टू रिपीटर इस वाले प भी आप आ
सकते हैं ठीक
है अब यहां पर मैं गो प क्लिक करता हूं इट
विल गिव यू द रीडायरेक्ट फॉलो डायरेक्शन
तो इट विल डायरेक्ट टू यर ठीक है बढ़िया
अब मैं यहां पे होस्ट के अलावा य होस्ट ही
पहले ते होस्ट चेंज करते www.b.com
गो इट विल बी रीडायरेक्शन नो नो
रीडायरेक्शन बंग नहीं कोई मैच नहीं है कोई
बात नहीं तो मैं क्या करता हूं होस्ट जो
पहले था वही रहने देते हैं और यहां पर
एक्स
फॉरवर्ड होस्ट जो है व यूज कर लेते हैं ब
क तो हमने य एक्स फरड होस्ट यूज किया एंड
य पर मैंने गो प क्लिक किया लेट अगेन देन
सेम थिंग अगेन ब क इ नॉट देयर सो नॉट ऑफ आ
यूज तो मैं य क्या कर
ट हटा देते हैं यहां पर होस्ट य रहने देते
रेफरर में हम चेंज करते हैं रेफरर को हम
www.bing.com यूज कर लेते
हैं गो प क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग 200 ओ के आ रहा है बड कॉ इ देयर
नोन be.com तो मैं इसको ओरिजिनल फॉर्म में
लेक आता हूं जो हमारा ओरिजिनल फॉर्म था
ठीक है इस पर आ जाते हैं अब हम होस्ट एक
और डाल देते हैं hb.com डाल देते
हैं ओवे सार है अगेन सेम तो नहीं है हमारा
ये टारगेट ओके चलिए तो इस तरीके से आपको
टेस्टिंग करनी है अलग-अलग टारगेट्स पे
अलग-अलग डोमेंस पे एंड आपको ट्राई करना है
ओपन डायरेक्शन वने बिलिटी फाइंड करने का
अब इसके अंदर ये ओपन डायरेक्शन वने बिलिटी
के अलावा भी बहुत कुछ होता है अगर आप
देखेंगे अ पोर्टस फिगर के ऊपर में तो यहां
पे आप
आएंगे देखो ये वही चीज लिखी हुई है
वर्चुअल होस्टिंग के बारे में ये आपको जो
मैंने आपको बताया इसको आप पढ़ लीजिएगा ठीक
है ना है ना कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तो
[संगीत]
यहां ये एक्सप्लोइटिंग क्लाइंट सर्वर साइड
वलने बिलिटी है बायपासिंग थ वर्चुअल होस्ट
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग ये सारी चीजें इसमें आती
है यहां पे एंड जब आपने ये देखा था ओस पली
तो आपको यहां पे दिख रहा होगा कि एक्स
फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट हेडर बायपास तो आप देख
सकते हैं एक्स फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट हेडर में
यहां पे इसने क्या किया अटैकर वाली जो
डोमेन है वो दे दी यहां पे एंड यहां पे जो
हमारा आपका डोमेन है जो विक्टिम का डोमेन
है वही रहेगा एक्पन में अटैकर का डोमेन
डाल दिया तो ये कई बार बा पास कर देता है
उसके बाद वेब कशनिंग पॉइजनिंग वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग होती है यहां पे कई बार ठीक है
जो कि लिंक्स के अंदर आपको एक रीडायरेक्शन
वाली यूआरएल मिल जाती है जैसे आपका अगर
वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग होगी ये हम देखेंगे अभी
नेक्स्ट क्लास में देखेंगे पासवर्ड रिसेट
पॉइजनिंग अभी वो देख लेंगे यहां पे
प्राइवेट वर्चुअल होस्ट को वो करना एंड
ओपन डायरेक्शन सो मेनली हमारे जो मेन
हमारा जो मोटिव था क्या था ओपन डायरेक्शन
वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग पासवर्ड रिसेट एक्सेस ये
सारी चीजें करना है ठीक है एसएसआरएफ को
अभी हम इसलिए हटा देते हैं क्योंकि
एसएसआरएफ टॉपिक ही नहीं किया हमने जब
करेंगे तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा वसे सिंपल
सा बस पेलो डालना है इससे सारे फॉली ट्राई
करना है तो ओपन डायरेक्शन का हमने यहां पे
देखा कि कैसे आपको ओपन डायरेक्शन फाइंड
करना है तो सिंपल हमें कैसे फाइंड करना है
यहां पे आपको ऑलरेडी बता दिया फाइंड करना
है वो सारे यूआरएल जो टू एक्सेसेस या थ्री
एक्सेसेस स्टेटस कोड्स के साथ आते हैं
सिंपल एज दैट उसके बाद आपको होस्ट हेडर को
यहां पे vc.com
रहेगा एंड यहां पे आप ऐड कर सकते हैं एक्स
फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट एक्स फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट
हेडर ऐड कर सकते हैं जो कि एक क्या होगा
यहां पे हैर कॉ हैर site.com ये रहेगा ठीक
है पहला तो यह कर सकते हैं दूसरा आप क्या
कर सकते हैं दूसरा हां मैं ऊपर के साइड
में ही कर देता
हूं मैं एक नया टप में कर देता हूं आपको
दिखेगा
य दूसरा अप्रोच में क्या कर सकते हैं
होस्ट में
आप होस्ट में आप ha.com रख सकते हैं एंड
एक्स
फॉरवर्ड होस्ट में आप विक्टिम कॉ लिख सकते
हैं विक्टिम कॉ कर सकते हैं य पे एक और आप
रेफरर हेडर का यूज कर सकते हैं एंड इसमें
आप हैकर साइड कॉ डाल के इस पर भी चेक आउट
कर सकते हैंप डायरेक्शन के लिए ठीक है समझ
में आ गया इतना कुछ आप कर सकते हैं ओपन
डायरेक्शन को अप्लाई करने के होस्टड
इंजेक्शन के थ्रू अब होस्ट इजेक्शन में
सिर्फ डायरेक्शन नहीं होती है देयर आर
मल्टीपल अदर वलन एबिलिटीज जैसे वेब कैस्ट
पॉइजनिंग पासवर्ड रिसेट अटैक एक्सेस अटैक
आप चाहे तो एकल इंजेक्शन फाइंड करने का
ट्राई कर सकते हैं आप चाहे तो एसएसआरएफ
वनबिल फाइंड करने का ट्राई कर सकते हैं और
भी मल्टीपल वनबिल आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं ठीक है बट स्टिल वी आर गोइंग टू कवर
दिस थिंग्स मुझे पहले आप बता दीजिए कि
होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन से ओपन डायरेक्शन का
कांसेप्ट समझ में आपको आया कि क्या होता
है किस तरीके से आप सिंपल सा यहां पे हेडर
के अंदर में होस्ट के हेडर को कॉ मिस
थोड़ा सा चेंज करके मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करने
की ट्राई कर सकते हैं एंड सर्वर अगर उसको
सही से रीड आउट नहीं करता है सर्वर उसको
सही से पार्स नहीं करता है एंड सर्वर
आंखें बंद करके बिल्कुल उसको एग्जीक्यूट
कर देता है एंड इट्स नॉट वेरीफाइंग और
वैलिडेटिंग द होस्ट सेडर देन इट कैन लीड
टू ओपन डायरेक्शन यह आपको समझ में आ गया
एवरीवन सर जी आप आज खुश होकर नहीं पढ़ा
रहे हैं क्योंकि मेरी तबीयत थोड़ी सी डाउन
है एंड दोपहर से ही डाउन लग रही है मुझे
तो इसलिए मैं डाउन डाउन फील कर रहा हूं
ट्स वई आई एम स्पीकिंग स्लोली एंड
सिंपली एक्स फॉरवर्ड जो होता है एक्स
फॉरवर्ड जो आपका एक्स फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट
होता है ये एक रिक्वेस्ट हेडर आपकी होती
है एसटीडीपी हेडर्स के अंदर
में आई एम फाइनली ऑन क्लास 21 आई एम
हैप्पी ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट
आपको जिनको एसटीडीपी हेडर्स के बारे में
नहीं पता मैंने आपसे पहले ही बोल दिया है
प्लीज आप सबसे रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप लोग हर
एक वीडियो को देखा कीजिए इट्स रिक्वेस्ट
मैंने ऑलरेडी इस पर एक अलग से क्लास ली
हुई थी स्पेशली इसीलिए ली हुई थी ताकि
आपको इन चीजों में दिक्कत ना हो जब आप
लाइव सेक्शन में जाएंगे तो यहां पर आप
देखेंगे डे 21 में एचटीटीपी हेडर्स को
मैंने बताया हुआ है तो आप इसको जरूर
देखिएगा आपको सारा कुछ क्लियर हो जाएगा
ठीक
है
ओ सो मैंने पहले ही बोला था कि आज मैं
ज्यादा ज्यादा लंबी क्लास नहीं लूंगा मेरे
को आज क्लास में ना वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग और
पासवर्ड रिसेट यह सभी कंप्लीट करने थे और
भी कुछ चीज आपको बतानी थी बट शायद मैं
नहीं कर पाऊंगा क्योंकि मुझे कुछ खास फील
तो हो नहीं रहा है अभी इन रियल में सो आई
वुड लाइक टू एंड द क्लास टुडे राइट हियर
मैं यही पेंड करना चाहूंगा एंड जो भी आपके
दोस्त वगैरह है आप उनके बीच शेयर कीजिए
हमारी वीडियो को हमारी क्लासेस को क्योंकि
हम फ्री में क्वालिटी कंटेंट देने की
कोशिश कर रहे हैं जो कि ऐसा बिल्कुल
कंटेंट नहीं है जो कि फ्री फ्री फ्री फ्री
टाइप कंटेंट हो आपको प्रीमियम कंटेंट देने
की कोशिश में कर रहा हूं इन एब्सलूट ट नो
कॉस्ट टू यू आपको कोई पैसे नहीं देने पड़
रहे इतना मुझे पता है ठीक है
बस
तो तो नेक्स्ट क्लास जल्दी ही आ जाएगी मैं
कोशिश करूंगा थोड़ा मैं ठीक होंगा नेक्स्ट
में ले लूंगा ठीक है जाते जाते लाइक ठोक
के जाइएगा 65 लाइक्स है ओनली 100 लाइक्स
तो हो ही जाने चाहिए ठीक है सो
प्लीज ओके और आप लोग ्र को जवाइन जरूर कर
लीजिएगा आप सबसे पहले ही मैंने बोल दिया
हुआ था कि व ग्रुप जो बनाया है मैंने यहां
पे
उसकी यहां पे लिंक थी हां यह लिंक है यह
वाली मैंने पिंड पिंड भी किया हुआ है लिंक
को ्र का इसी चैट में पिंड है तो आप प्लीज
अ पिन चैट से
[संगीत]